hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast live single-cell
phenotypic biomarkers measured from
primary biopsy samples an emerging class
of biomarkers to write the development
of precision diagnostics and the
discovery of and development presented
by Ashlyn Shonda he is the co-founder
and CEO of Sonic's I am Marjorie
Torrance of lab routes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labrys lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
anytime you want during the presentation
just click on the green Q&A button
located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appears on
the screen when answer as many of your
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you'll be viewing the presentation
in the slide window to enlarge the
window just click on the screen icon
located on the lower right if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Ashraf shatter I will now turn the
presentation over to him Thank You
Marjorie this is a great pleasure to be
able to speak to you around this topic
of lifestyle phenotypic biomarkers
specifically from primary biopsy cells
and we what I'll present to you is
evidence suggests that these are a new
class of biomarkers that are useful for
precision diagnostics and the discovery
and development of personalized
therapy's specifically what I'll go
through is why machine vision and
machine learning are extremely important
for this process towards understanding
live cell dynamics as well as tissue co
culture and single-cell resolution so we
all are very well well aware of the the
need for the and the importance of
precision diagnostics and personalized
therapies and in solid tumors
we've been subject to classic techniques
that have yielded the results that we
see today and a lot of these types of
cancers lung prostate breast cancers for
example are still very much in need for
personalized therapies for example and
prostate cancer castration is still a
viable mode of treatment so in order to
really get at personalized and precision
medicine we need to think about
approaching current diagnostic and
current drug development techniques in a
different way specifically the problem
as we're learning is of course the idea
of tumor heterogeneity of course not
only are there desert differences
between the cancer within patients but
there's also differences within the same
patient as well as for example in a
prostate two different lesions within
that prostate will have different
molecular profiles and even within one
profile there will be variations among
cells so what we're finding is and what
everyone is certainly excited about is
the prospect of being able to analyze
and interrogate biopsy samples tumor
tissue patient samples on a single cell
level but not just from one one level of
regulation as mean
cancer is a very complex problem and so
perhaps we might want to apply the full
central dogma to it or interrogate the
full central dogma to it and not just
one level or aspect of it
towards an aim
sille annex the company that I
represented the CEO and founder
developed a platform what we term strat
X and this platform enables a culturing
of primary biopsy cells for automated
multi-omics and what I mean by that is
phenotypic and genotypic proteomic level
type high throughput and high content
analysis so let me walk you through what
the strattice platform does quickly we
were the Shred exit platform was able to
take a biopsy self from VOR that biopsy
cell is able to be transported given
given a media formulation from the o.r
to a central laboratory within the
hospital or external and then that
biopsy sample is dissociated into
various levels of resolution to be able
to be placed on a microfluidic device
that then can be imaged through a micro
through microscopy once the biomarkers
and images of interest are collected
machine vision software and then simply
analyze objectively and quantify
biomarkers from those digitized images
and seamlessly those quantifications
then get input into machine learning
derive statistical algorithms that can
generate predictive metrics predictive
metrics that can facilitate the
understanding of a clinical outcome such
as metastasis local progression
therapy response and even upstream of
that biomarker validation and so the
point being there's a there's a
versatility both in the front-end of the
platform as well as in the backend and
as much as number of biopsies can be
taken and cultured and then a number of
predictions can be had importantly this
this process is actually quite quick and
and automated so the most
labor-intensive step is quite frankly
taking the biopsy out of the box that
has been received in and then placed
into a buffer but then moves the process
along moves the sample along this
process of an incubation and then a
normalization process it's normalized
specifically to an extracellular matrix
formulation that not only keeps the
cells alive but then promotes the cells
to react in very specific ways that
might be interesting for the prediction
of interest then there's a sample
imaging which can be anywhere around
five hours and then the data analysis
which is done on the cloud that will
yield predictive metrics here's an
example on slide seven of the the way
that cells look within the platform in
the microscope we have primary actually
an example as here's the primary
biopsies of prostate cancer cells each
cell is actually identified and tracked
by the machine vision software and then
during that tracking of course biomarker
measurements can be measured through the
machine vision algorithms we can play
this video that would give you a better
sense of how dynamic these cells are and
also one might be able to appreciate
how - how
how many biomarkers and how many dynamic
biomarkers are and a tremendous amount
of value to the analysis of these cells
so perhaps we'll get back to that video
but just
so to go back to the to go back to the
brief clip of the video perhaps we can
play that a little later at the end of
the presentation but the idea of that
video is and and the analysis of course
is to measure dynamic biomarkers and
then associate them with molecular and
perhaps more traditionally static
biomarkers and so on this slide slide 8
we see that a kind of a representative
grouping of some of the biomarkers that
can be measured on the strata kinetics
platform and so for example we see
adhesion again these cells are
interacting with a very defined extra so
their matrix so their human
characteristics will be very telling
with respect to their their integrand
and their way the ways that they might
generally interact with the
intracellular matrix as the cells spread
on in the in the in vitro environment we
can also assess the morphology and the
molecular dynamics as well as the
cellular dynamics that also give really
good insights into specific ensembles of
protein complexes such as the rack row
and GT bas complexes that govern actin
signaling after the live cell dynamics
are measured the cells are fixed and
then the cells were our probe for for
fixed and proteins so to look at or or
even RNA to look at localization
expression and
modification states and what's
interesting though is that when after
all these analysis are done we're able
to assess these biomarkers and create
aggregate biomarkers proprietary
aggregate biomarkers that actually are
pretty interesting and useful in in
terms of clinical predictions I'll get
back to that a little later so just
thinking about it from from a high level
the strata X platform is very adept at
measuring both dynamic and fixed
biomarkers and one can think of these as
multi-omics biomarkers cellular and
molecular specifically dynamic cellular
biomarkers and 6lu biomarkers and
dynamic molecular and fixed molecular
biomarkers and it transverses the the
levels of regulation that are
responsible for the disease and
pathology that patients experience from
DNA to RNA to protein to cellular
interaction with the extracellular
matrix or with other cells so the power
of products is also based on the ability
to measure multiple different types of
samples and so what we're talking about
is not just the ability to measure from
biopsy cells but we can measure from
blood and urine cells derived from these
these samples have interesting touch
points within the treatment paradigm
specifically at least traditionally
blood and urine are are adept and and
great candidates those samples are great
candidates for screening technologies or
screening applications
conversely biopsy samples are more
at maybe diagnostic or prognostic
applications and so the point here is
that simply live cell phenotypic
diagnostics and live cell phenotypic
biomarkers can be toggled or applied to
various applications within the
treatment paradigm largely I think based
on the sample input and the value of
what of the of these biomarkers is what
we'll get into a little later but
certainly the increased sensitivity and
specificity of our predictions within
diagnostics and prognostics touch points
could easily be replicated and
recapitulate it in the screening aspects
as well so here's just a quick overview
again of the strannix platform and then
tying it to specific predictive metrics
so well moving forward we'll be talking
mostly about the prostate and we
approach a biopsy is taken presumably
it's taken from the lesion that core has
been placed in a tube filled with
cultural media as opposed to formal
fixative that that tube is then packaged
on on ice or compacts and transported
within 72 hours to a central laboratory
where it can then be processed by the
Association normalization and then
loaded onto a microfluidic device for
for image analysis towards biomarker
quantification by machine vision and
then of course after those biomarkers
are quantified they're they're put into
machine learning derive statistical
algorithms to predict and so the example
that we'll be moving forward with is the
ability
predict whether a patient experiences
surgical adverse pathologies and these
these predictions are very useful in
terms of patient stratification for
example at least at 6:00 or at least in
seven patient may need to understand
whether they're at risk being up
traditionally or classically defined
low-risk or an immediate risk patient
whether they're at risk for being our
having a circle at Versailles ecology to
understand whether or not to go through
active surveillance or to undergo a
definitive treatment and so be to do
that we've we've created predictive
metrics and again what we'll do is we'll
get into that a bit later beyond just
that ability to use the test as a
patient sure to get patient risk
stratification tests there are upstream
applications of this platform that can
also be useful for the development of
precision personalized medicine
specifically when therapeutics are being
developed the ability to rapidly culture
primary cells as opposed to using cell
lines or as opposed to using animal
models can be very important the ability
to look at multiple levels of regulation
or that multi-omics approach could also
be very important towards understanding
the the complexity of the diseases that
we're trying to target as well as the
high throughput analysis of machine
vision and the predictive nature of
machine learning and so in addition to
being a risk stratification test this
this shred X platform has many up
streamed out applications for with
respect to a therapy selection
actually some downstream applications
with respect to patient treatment in
terms of in terms of monitoring if the
patient is actually responding to a
therapy or a treatment and actually
deciding whether that treatment is
appropriate before the patient undergoes
that treatment so here we are in terms
of looking at the first major key
capability of this platform and this
platform is hinged upon the ability to
keep primary body cells alive and in the
panel on on your left you'll see various
groupings of controls glass poly lacing
and laminin classic surfaces that people
culture or cells on when we when we coat
these when we coke glass or plastic with
the Strada X ECM F or extracellular
matrix formulation we see a very robust
response by primary biopsy cells to
adhere and survive and behave in a in a
in a meaningfully referenceable way and
we shown that this ECM map or exercising
metric formulation can not only keep
cells alive across you know multiple
days but even beyond over the course of
30 days we haven't tested beyond 30 days
but these it's exciting to know that we
can rapidly culture these cells and then
they can survive in a relatively long
period of time so at least in the
context in the application of clinical
diagnostics and therapeutic development
so now that we have the cells alive we
certainly want to make sure that we can
objectively measure them and quantify
important biomarkers or or features or
behaviors of these cells and I think
this is it it's important to note that
the objective nature of this
quantification is is kind of critical to
the next steps of the platform without
consists in objective measurement of
biomarkers of interest the machine
learning learning algorithm will just
not behave or be trained properly and
and so the old adage goes garbage in and
garbage out so we want to ensure that
the data that is being input or that is
actually being observed and measured
from ash Rennicks
platform is as objective as possible and
as robust as possible such that the
machine learning algorithm is going to
be as smart as possible so once we are
able to actually employ machine learning
then a whole new world if you will opens
up we can take live cells we can choose
which biomarkers are of interest to us
given a vast sweep of okay and
multi-omics biomarkers and and then
based and rather than us or the operator
choosing those biomarkers of importance
we let and train the machine learning
out with them to decide and arrive at an
appropriate ranking of those biomarkers
for example if one is going to predict
metastasis in breast cancer versus
metastasis and prostate cancer given the
same set of biomarkers again a very vast
parker's it's the hypothesis of course
and what we proved to be is it's proved
and we've shown and demonstrated is that
those biomarkers are very different but
we did not pick those biomarkers rather
the machine learning algorithm decided
upon those biomarkers and there's a
there's there's also you know the
statistics behind that are just very
overwhelming and leads to further
predictions and further intelligent
predictions both by the operator and by
the Machine these these predictions are
can be very vast and varied you know not
just from a prognostic approach but
again upstream in in terms of therapies
of development as well as downstream and
patient in patient care so on this slide
we see actually the value of this
approach and so as an example
application of strata X we've
demonstrated that this platform is able
to predict surgical adverse pathologies
for prostate cancer and again those are
but that's the gold standard or prostate
cancer diagnosis in as much as the
prostate is removed and interrogated by
the pathologist to understand what
exactly happened within the prostate and
being able to predict that certainly
before the surgery is a very important
and one might consider the holy grail of
prostate cancer diagnosis and to be and
so what we've done is we've taken 238
samples of patient samples and predicted
that with relatively high since the visa
specificities and this data was
presented in the America numerological
Association in 2016 and
I received a best poster award for a
prostate cancer biomarkers for a
stratification what's also interesting
and kind of going back to the point that
I may have alluded to earlier is that
given this this breadth of biomarkers
one can make multiple date multiple
predictions with different rankings in
these biomarkers we were also able to
predict using Strad acts surgical
adverse pathology features even if the
tumor or rather the biopsy missed the
tumor and so of course in the field or
in the state-of-the-art rather this is
termed the field effect or around the
tumor there is a region of tissue that
wall might not look like tumor from a
histopathology standpoint there are
molecular changes that occur in that
tissue that define it as abnormal
essentially and these this the suite of
biomarkers that shred X actually has was
able to pick out those patients from the
field effect that would actually
experience adverse pathology and so
again just using this as an example and
why we should think about live cell
phenotypic biomarkers and live so multi
approaches as being meaningful we can
compare this approach this red X
approach with other fixed cell and
genomic approaches and so as a previous
slide alluded to in terms of prognostics
the Gleason score is roughly 60 to 70%
accurate as a prognostic in terms of
prognostics and being able to predict
certain adverse pathologies genomic
approach is also just purely based on
their biomarkers our
some 80% accurate and so just above
clinical noise we find that in our
results with similar patient numbers in
terms of our clinical trial these
dynamic biomarkers are actually
achieving better performance with
respect to prediction not only that but
it's it avoids repeat biopsies by being
able to predict even if the patient even
if a tumor or even if the brother the
biopsy misses a tumor it's it's faster
and efficient in terms of workflow which
I'll get into a bit later and it turns
out to be a little more cost effective
so in terms of workflow we see that the
Gleason score usually takes around seven
days for a pathologist to return that
there's a number of processes involved
in terms of preparing the the biopsy
core and then standing in and observing
it and the genomic workflow takes a
little longer specifically because the
pathologist is asked to identify tumor
rich cores to send to the genetic
analysis to send for genetic glasses the
selects workflow actually is simplified
and one might think that it's more
complex given that that's using live
cells there's actually simplified in as
much as because this destroyed X
platform only needs one biopsy in as
much as it can predict from tumor or
adjacent or normal tissue it just needs
one biopsy core that biopsy core can
then be placed in a media that then is
put into a a transport box filled with
ice packs and then sent to a central
laboratory and and that workflow it's
resonated quite nicely with the with the
practicing physicians
that we've shared that with and so what
we're seeing now is and what's emerging
and what we will see is that the hundred
years of using histopathology and some
odd 34 years now that were being really
excited about the promise of genomics
may yield to an actual multi-omics
approach and while the discovery of DNA
in 1960 was very exciting and and while
that afforded us a tremendous amount of
advances of information in biology it
doesn't it wasn't meant to actually
prevent us from taking the next step in
the central dogma and understanding the
other aspects and other regular levels
of regulation towards really precision
or really developing precision
Diagnostics towards personalized
therapies and so what we see here is
that the strattice platform as an
example of a live cell Y primary cell
platform has many applications we can
use it in biomarker validation therapy
selection patient stratification and
then certainly those being part of the
therapy the the drug development pathway
and then in the clinical landscape we
can think about it as being a diagnostic
of prognostic or companion diagnostic
and so here's some data just to kind of
give you an example of how all this can
all of this is working and can work so
key to the strategy platform is the
ability to actually interrogate biopsy
samples with single-cell resolution so
on the left you see a graph
of each each point being a single cell
and their measurement for one given
biopsy and these these cells that are
above the dotted line are predicted as
being positive by the machine learning
algorithm and one can who can understand
how if one would add a drug and then
push all those cells down below the
threshold one might have a very positive
and predictive and useful drug on their
hand so similarly we can place this
general concept of single-cell
resolution and translating that
information into a patient level
prediction into other types of useful
analyses specifically within drug
development for example biomarker
identification or biomarker validation
one of course would would know the
clinical endpoint that the biomarker is
going to be useful for and so one can
start probing different biomarkers and
understanding those perturbations and
whether they actually affect the the
prediction of the clinical outcome that
is needed and again this is a this is a
two step process and as much as one
would predict patient behavior based on
single cell results and then by
perturbing that those single cell
results see how that shift in patient
behavior occurs to understand whether
that specific biomarker or that specific
compound
is of interest so kind of a very simple
way of thinking about it is the
strattice platform is able to predict
whether a patient is
positive or negative on the x-axis for a
given adverse pathology or a given
outcome let's call it metastasis and so
this patient is negative or positive it
determines what the patient needs
therapy or not on the y-axis we see that
the this platform of Shraddha X can also
predict if the patient when treated
would be positive or negative and so
essentially this the platform can be
applied to predict the responders of
therapy by identifying those patients
that would be positive for metastases
and then also the responders of the
therapy and as much as them it's that
medicine behavior of the cells would be
diminished if you will by the addition
of the therapy and that's of course in
the bottom right quadrant of that graph
so that's just a quick look into some of
the capabilities and applications
I think of live cell phenomics and and
live primary cell phenomics and and the
ability of course to keep ourselves
alive the measure biomarkers objectively
with machine vision and leverage machine
learning for important predictive
metrics certainly has a tremendous
amount of application across both the
Rd as well as clinical treatment
paradigms not only within oncology but
in other disease states specifically the
product diseases as well as giving
cardiology and and metabolic diseases so
in summary what what I just wanted to
kind of emphasize is that it's the rapid
culturing of these cells that makes
things meaningful both within the
context of developing drugs as well as
in the context of clinical Diagnostics
then certainly if the versatility of
being able to Cole culture not just
single cells but different types of
cells together which aids in the ability
to understand cell the cell interactions
for those similar applications
high-throughput analysis and then most
importantly the objective analysis by
machine vision and the predictive
capabilities of machine learning really
take and move what what might be
considered a very old idea of phenomics
into very relevant and actually perhaps
even more important stance and beyond
just have the tools aspect we see a
tremendous amount of potential with
therapeutic development throughout the
pipeline of biomarker discovery lead
compound development stratify patients
within clinical trials understanding
patient response and then certainly in
the context of clinical Diagnostics is
the data that we just we just talked
about supports so I do want to take a
quick moment to recognize the team that
built shred X Michael my neck is the the
primary cell biologist and Jonathan
arsenic is the primary computer
scientist a great number of important
and thoughtful advisors starting on the
bottom right Sam CIA professor at
Columbia University involved in
microfluidic design and diagnostic
development the chair of urology Eric
client of Cleveland Clinic dr. Eric
Cline Cavanaugh health economics and
breast cancer expert doctor
dr. kovala that again a chief of
neurology at a Kraus Hospital in New
York and the former chair of urology at
Tufts doctor madam sent and dr. Praveen
Chaturvedi is a is a expert at drug
development and candidate optimization
with that I'm happy to take any
questions thank you thank you dr.
Sanders for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window type your questions into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for let's get started our
first question is what are the key
technology features that enable
lifestyle phenotypic analysis yes the
key the key features I think are one of
course the ability to rapidly keep cells
alive and not just in not just on the
device or not just with it on top of the
microscope but in transport and then of
course the ability to have a good suite
of biomarkers that are interest to
whatever general area or indication one
is interested in and then three of
course the the Machine vision that we
talked about towards objectively
quantifying the biomarkers and then
finally because there there may be a
number
bio markers and a number of systems
being interrogated the machine learning
helps a great deal towards of
prioritizing what actually is important
towards the prediction of interest and
so it's a hard question because they all
have almost similar weights but I would
I would say that you know of course one
won't work well together thank you for
that answer our next question is what
are the most promising applications of
utilizing lifestyle phenotypic
biomarkers so I'm not I'm not sure if I
heard that question probably you repeat
that question
okay so our next question is what are
the most promising applications of
utilizing live cell phenotypic
biomarkers thank you so I think the most
promising applications of phenotypic
biomarkers are the ability to risk
stratify patients because that currently
there are no precision tools to do that
this is the biggest unmet need I believe
in clinical treatment as well as even
drug development the ability to
understand which patient has a severe
defect in a pathway or has a or even as
generalized
is gonna is gonna have a metastatic
disease or local aggressive disease I
think this is the biggest need for this
type of test it as much as their the
ability to do that will then allow for
other advances in other areas for
example the ability to properly rashard
that patients will make it easier to
develop therapies and and and the
ability to properly risk ratified
patients will also enable better
treatment for patients so I think the
the most important and promising
application of live cell phenotypic
biomarkers in as much as diseases are
dynamic diseases are complex the
understanding of dynamic biomarkers may
add important information to that
understanding is really an actual risk
stratification and patient and patient
kind of categorization thank you
our next question is how long does it
take to analyze a sample thank you so I
think generally it depends on how many
thought markers one wants to measure but
in our experience it's it's been 12
hours to receive a sample we've pushed
that out up to 72 hours just to test our
ability to do that and then beyond
actual sample receipt the disassociation
and normalization process takes another
12 hours roughly and then the analysis
can take anywhere between 5 to 10 hours
depending on what one might want to
measure and then the data analysis can
can be condensed to you know one hour
depending on computing power so you know
we're looking at within two to three
days whereas the current diagnostic
current assay systems are potentially
over weeks so this is a big advance
ended of itself on top of the actual
advance of being able to measure dynamic
biomarkers
okay it looks like we have time for one
more question our last question is what
contributes to the predictive power of
lifestyle phenotypic biomarker analysis
thank you that that's a very important
question and one that I don't really
exactly have the answer to at the moment
again I think I'd have to go back to
just the idea of looking at multiple
levels of regulation of the cell
it'd be the ability to not just look at
one aspect or DNA or RNA or protein or
even cell but to look at multiple level
of regulation but then also look at them
in a dynamic way given the fact that
these diseases operate in a very dynamic
fashion and then I think that
flexibility is its leverage by machine
learning and so then I think my lack of
understanding of this perhaps is because
you know to understand all of the
biomarkers that are being assessed by
all of the all of the machine learning
is very is very challenging perhaps even
for my simple brain and so the ability
for to leverage artificial intelligence
as a word to then sequentially measure
and analyze and compare thousands of
biomarkers over thousands of cells
essentially 45 million measurements per
sample and then come up with a ranking
of those
those biomarkers over the multiple
levels of regulation again I think that
is that systems approach and that
computational approach are the two keys
of its predictive performance thank you
I would like to once again thank dr.
Alexander with his presentation I would
also like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational web cats possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through January of
2018 you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcements with your
colleagues you that may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye